Hi, this is Presh Talwalkar.
Let's discuss an interesting infinite fraction.
Let's say you need to solve for x
in the equation, x equals one plus one over one plus one over one plus... et cetera, repeating infinitely.
How would you solve for x?
If you want to take a stab at the problem, you can pause the video. Otherwise, keep watching for the solution.
The trick is to observe a pattern.
If you circle the terms under the denominator,
one plus one over one plus... et cetera,
This exactly is equal to the variable x.
This means we can replace everything under the denominator with the variable x.
And thus, we have the equation "x equals one plus one over x."
If we multiply both sides by x, we get x squared equals x plus one.
We can solve this with the quadratic formula.
x equals (One plus or minus the square root of five) over two.
Since x only had positive terms, we get rid of the negative solution.
So x is equal to 1.618,
And this is the Golden Ratio.
Please subscribe to my channel.
You can support me on Patreon.
Catch me on my blog, Mind Your Decisions,
On twitter, at "Presh Talwalkar,"
And get my E-Books at Amazon.